you're trying to solve a problem right
editor what we call a unstructured
problem so it's kind of like well I
don't even know how to go about this
it's not like solving 2x minus 1 equals
3 this is a structured problem I know
exactly what to do with this I go step
step step there's my answer
ok the problem I've given you it's kind
of like where do I even start so when
you've got another structured problem
right I don't know how much like if
you've gone to mass enrichment some like
that but one of the key strategies for
problem solving is take your problem
simplify it down a little bit and see if
you can solve that and then can you work
out any principles from that so I'm just
thinking about one solitary bit ok
that's all I want to send to you suppose
I want to send you a one okay now let's
just agree ok that we'll use even parity
today so if I'm sending your one I have
to have a parity bit on the end as well
right so to make it even what should I
add a 1 ok so that is the message I'm
going to send along to you ok 1 1 now
because I'm sending 2 bits there are
other ways I could get this wrong that
interference would come in right I put
on or you could receive 1 0 or you could
receive 0 1 or you could receive 0 0 or
you can receive 1 1 okay
now other words in this example there
are three different kinds of errors
that's it there are no other
alternatives right because all I'm
sending is 2 bits okay
now out of these three errors which ones
will you pick up we've agreed upon even
parity right well let's figure out this
one ok 1 0 when that arrives your
computer and you're like hmm is this
what was sent or not your computer will
say no we cop it impossible because it's
not even there's not an even number of
words ok so your computer be like
whatever you understand that wasn't in
this is garbage
ok what about this 1 0 1 will your
computer pick it up it'll recognize
right this is also garbage because
there's not an even number of what ok or
an even number of zeros I hope you seen
by the way because everything is always
in lots of
to an even number of ones implies an
even number of zeroes right and an odd
number of ones implies an odd number of
zeroes so I could have said ones a zeros
don't matter now that's a good last one
zero zero will your computer pick that
up
will that regice start this as an error
it won't right
because we'll say does it have an even
number of zeros does it have an even
number of ones yes it does so that could
be it that could be the message that was
set so in this example out of the three
errors I only will you only picked up
two - were actually registered the other
one got through okay so I guess I would
say two out of three or 66% of errors
would get checked and actually
recognized okay and 32 people don't go
through now is it always 66% everyone's
is the extent 50 which is not that high
66 and 50s a big difference right so
this is an example with I wanted to send
one bit what would happen if you changed
it if you say went to two bits three or
four that's actually what I want you to
think about